A few years back, a science fiction writer and fan named Stephen Goldin was preparing for an upcoming sci-fi convention. And he thought that it might ease some of the awkward situations that he had seen at conventions in the past if he would just write up a few simple guidelines for the fans on how to act when they get to meet, one on one, some of the professional writers who they admired so much. Some of his tips-- I have them here.
几年前，一位名叫斯蒂芬·戈尔丁的科幻作家兼粉丝正为即将到来的科幻大会做准备。他想到，如果能为粉丝们写几条简单的行为准则，告诉他们在与自己崇拜的专业作家面对面交流时该如何表现，或许能缓解他在过去的大会上所见过的某些尴尬场面。他的一些建议——我这里有。
Don't delay the pro on his way to the restroom and try to start a long conversation.
不要在专业人士去洗手间的路上拦住他们，试图开启一段冗长的谈话。
If a pro is involved in another conversation, do not interrupt. Wait until a break.
如果一位专业人士正在与他人交谈，请勿打断。等到休息时间再说。
In talking to a pro, keep it light. If you want a detailed philosophical discussion, make an appointment. Don't be a sponge. Buy your fair share of drinks and meals. Twenty-three different rules, ending with the most important. Don't insult the pro.
与专业人士交谈时，保持轻松愉快。如果你想进行深入的哲学探讨，请预约。别做一个“海绵”。自己买份酒水或餐点。这是二十三条规则中的最后一条，也是最重要的一条：不要冒犯专业人士。
Why would rules as basic as this even be necessary?
为什么这些基本的规则竟然是必要的？
The science fiction fans are usually the people who have been sort of the social outcasts when they were growing up in school. When everyone else was out playing sports or going to parties, the fans were in their rooms reading. And so they didn't develop a lot of the social skills their peers did and they grew up being introverts. And so when you get to a science fiction convention, you get a convention of introverts, which is a very strange social phenomenon.
科幻迷通常是那些在学校成长过程中属于某种“社交异类”的人。当其他人出去参加运动或派对时，这些粉丝却躲在房间里看书。因此，他们没有培养出同龄人那样的社交能力，长大后往往性格内向。所以当你去参加科幻大会时，你会置身于一群内向者的聚会中，这是一种非常奇怪的社会现象。
Have you seen fans try to follow the pros to the bathroom?
你见过粉丝试图跟踪专业人士进洗手间吗？
Yeah.
见过。
Well, I bring all this up to say that it is not just science fiction fans who need simple guidelines like these. Reading Stephen Goldin's 23 rules online, I realize, to my embarrassment, that in putting together this week's radio show, we have violated eight of the 23 rules. Eight. This week, we visited with a variety of different kinds of pros, and we monopolized their time, we interrupted, we got into detailed philosophical discussions uninvited. We did not pick up the check. Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
嗯，我提出这些是为了说明，不仅是科幻迷需要这样的简单准则。在网上读了斯蒂芬·戈尔丁的23条规则后，我尴尬地意识到，在制作本周的广播节目时，我们竟然违反了其中的八条。八条啊。这周，我们拜访了各种各样的专业人士，我们垄断了他们的时间，我们打断了他们，我们在未经邀请的情况下进行了深入的哲学讨论。我们还没买单。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和公共广播国际的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Today's show, Meet the Pros. Stories of amateurs hurdling themselves at the professionals whose jobs they would like to have, for better or for worse. Our show today in three acts.
今天的节目主题是“遇见专业人士”。讲述的是业余爱好者们奔向他们梦想从事的职业领域中专业人士的故事，无论好坏。今天的节目分为三个部分。
Act one, Crispy With the Rock. The star of what is arguably the world's greatest sneaker commercial, and whether it is possible for our correspondent, little grasshopper, to grab the basketball from his hand. Act two, Know When to Walk Away, Know When to Run. In which I explain how I went to the World Series of Poker as a reporter and came away completely obsessed with the game, reading about it, playing online to an extent that I have not completely admitted to my own family until this very hour. Act three, Martha, My Dear. David Rakoff goes behind the scenes at Martha Stewart Living to find out the answer to the question, if his hobby became his job, would it still be fun? Stay with us.
第一部分，“脆皮与摇滚”。讲述的是可以说是世界上最棒的运动鞋广告的主角，以及我们的记者“小蚱蜢”是否有可能从他手中夺过篮球。第二部分，“知进退，知去留”。我将解释作为一名记者，我如何前往世界扑克大赛并彻底沉迷于这款游戏，甚至读相关书籍、玩线上游戏，直到此时此刻才完全向我的家人坦白。第三部分，“亲爱的玛莎”。大卫·拉科夫走进《玛莎·斯图尔特生活》杂志幕后，寻找一个答案：如果爱好变成了工作，它还会是有趣的吗？请继续收听。
Act one, Crispy With the Rock.
第一部分，“脆皮与摇滚”。
This is the story of two amateurs meeting the pros. One of the amateurs, a teenager in New Jersey. The other, our correspondent, Joel Lovell.
这是两位业余爱好者遇见专业人士的故事。其中一位是新泽西州的一名少年。另一位是我们的记者，乔尔·洛弗尔。
And before we get started, I should say that today's show was first broadcast in 2001. And so the amazing TV commercial that they're talking about in this story, it's something that aired back then. OK, here's Joel.
在开始之前，我应该说明，今天的节目首播于2001年。所以他们在这个故事中谈到的那个神奇的电视广告，是当时播出的。好了，下面是乔尔。
This is the sound of me dribbling a basketball.
这是我拍打篮球的声音。
[DRIBBLING]
[拍球声]
Now this is Luis Da Silva dribbling a basketball.
现在这是路易斯·达·席尔瓦拍打篮球的声音。
[DRIBBLING]
[拍球声]
Luis is in the Nike commercial-- Freestyle, it's called-- that ran on TV throughout the NBA playoffs this past spring. If you haven't seen it, the commercial features a bunch of NBA stars and some WNBA stars and a bunch of street ballplayers. Guys with names like Speedy and A Train and The Future performing a series of spectacular tricks. Dribbling and passing and twirling basketballs, sort of like the Harlem Globetrotters. But a lot faster and a lot cooler, and to this incredibly infectious hip-hop beat. So their dribbling sounds like music.
路易斯出演了耐克广告——叫《花式》，今年春天在NBA季后赛期间在电视上反复播放。如果你没看过，这个广告里有许多NBA球星、一些WNBA球星和一堆街头篮球手。那些名字听起来像“极速”、“火车”和“未来”的家伙们表演了一系列壮观的技巧。运球、传球、转球，有点像哈林篮球队。但速度更快、更酷，配上那种极具感染力的嘻哈节拍。所以他们的运球声听起来就像音乐一样。
In May and June, the ads were airing in pretty heavy rotation, and I found myself spending a lot of hours watching games I didn't really care about. Games involving the Indiana Pacers, for instance. Just so I could see the commercial.
在五月和六月，这些广告的播放频率非常高，我发现自己花了很多时间看我并不关心的比赛。比如涉及印第安纳步行者队的比赛。仅仅是为了看那个广告。
Technically, there are three different versions of the ad. A long two and a half minute spot involving all the players, then a similar shorter one. And then a 30-second spot that features only Luis, a 19-year-old kid from Linden, New Jersey who can do things with a basketball that if you're serious basketball lover-- well, they just make you want to die, they're so great.
从技术上讲，该广告有三个不同版本。一个两分半钟的长版，涉及所有球员；然后是一个类似的较短版本。还有一个30秒的版本，只以路易斯为主角，他是新泽西州林登市一个19岁的孩子，他能用篮球做出的动作，如果你是一个真正的篮球爱好者——嗯，它们太棒了，简直让你想死。
Linden is a working class suburb just south of Newark. Luis's family moved here a few years ago, so that he and his sister could go to a safer school. It's a nice neighborhood. The houses and lawns are well kept. It's not at all the kind of gritty, urban neighborhoods where serious street ballplayers make their names.
林登是纽瓦克以南的一个工薪阶层郊区。路易斯的家人几年前搬到这里，这样他和他的妹妹就能去一所更安全的学校。这是一个很不错的社区。房子和草坪都打理得很好。这里完全不是那种街头篮球手成名的粗犷都市社区。
This is actually my room right here. This is where I stand in the mirror. Because I'm always in the mirror trying to figure out new moves. It's like my workout screen.
这就是我的房间。这是我对着镜子站的地方。因为我总是在镜子前试图琢磨新动作。这就像我的训练屏幕。
He shows me the walls of his room, and they're like the walls of a lot of 19-year-old guys' rooms. There are some photos of souped-up cars, and one of a motorcycle in mid-flight, and there are a bunch of posters of Luis's basketball heroes.
他给我看他房间的墙壁，它们就像许多19岁男生的房间墙壁一样。有一些改装车的照片，还有一张摩托车在飞行途中的照片，还有一堆路易斯的篮球英雄海报。
You see a lot of Iverson and Steve France. Then right here you got Michael. Everybody got a picture with Jordan.
你可以看到很多艾弗森和史蒂夫·弗朗西斯的照片。然后这里有迈克尔。每个人都有一张和乔丹的合影。
And there, to the right of Jordan, a full-sized color poster of Luis. And to Jordan's left, some one-of-a-kind Luis memorabilia.
在乔丹右边，有一张路易斯的全尺寸彩色海报。而在乔丹左边，有一些路易斯独有的纪念品。
And that's actually the same shorts I wore in the commercial. My mother did that for me. She put it in a little frame.
那其实就是我在广告里穿的同一条短裤。我母亲帮我做的。她把它装进了一个小框里。
This is the story of how Luis, who is not a basketball star, who in fact didn't even make the starting five on his high school team, ended up on the same wall beside all his idols.
这就是路易斯的故事，他不是篮球明星，事实上他甚至没能进入高中校队的首发五虎，但他最终却和所有的偶像并排挂在墙上。
We sit in Luis's living room and he tells me his story from the beginning. He's been playing basketball since he was 11, when he lived in Elizabeth, New Jersey. The nearest park was pretty dangerous. And because his mother didn't want Luis going there alone, he ended up dribbling a ball in his own backyard, a concrete slab about the size of a Twister mat.
我们坐在路易斯的客厅里，他从头开始给我讲他的故事。他从11岁起就开始打篮球，那时他住在新泽西州的伊丽莎白。最近的公园相当危险。因为他母亲不想让路易斯一个人去那里，他最终在自家后院运球，那是一块大约只有“扭扭乐”垫子大小的混凝土板。
He would dribble from morning till night, watching his reflection in a basement window. Trying to repeat exactly the same moves again and again. His neighbors, who were often kept awake by his dribbling, thought he was out of his mind.
他会从早到晚运球，看着地下室窗户里的倒影。试图一遍又一遍地重复同样的动作。他的邻居们经常被他的运球声吵醒，觉得他疯了。
When my father called me in, he's like, son, it's time to come in now. I'm like, what time is it? He's like, it's 2:30. I was like, wow. Time just came by. Time just flew.
当我父亲叫我进去时，他说，儿子，现在该进去了。我说，几点了？他说，两点半了。我说，哇。时间过得真快。时间就这样飞逝。
And I would wake up the next day during sometime like 9, 10 o'clock and get like four or five hours of sleep. Back up. But I wanted it so bad. I wanted it so bad.
我会第二天在九点、十点左右醒来，只睡了四五个小时。又起来了。但我太渴望它了。我太渴望它了。
I was just in my backyard. That's how much I loved it. I mean, nothing else mattered. Nothing else mattered. Wasn't on the phone much. I wasn't even concerned about going out with my friends and going to the movies. I loved it so much. And I just wanted to be the best at what I do and dribbling and having the nicest handle around and nothing else mattered.
我就在我的后院里。这就是我有多爱它。我的意思是，其他一切都不重要。其他一切都不重要。我不怎么打电话。我甚至不关心和朋友们出去看电影。我太爱它了。我只想在我做的事情上做到最好，在运球上，拥有周围最棒的控球技术，其他都不重要。
Nicest handle, maddest handle. Do him dirty, break him down. Like any specialized world, street basketball has its own language spoken by experts. And the lingo sounds so cool to me, but also sounds so uncool when spoken by me, that I ask Luis to elaborate on some of the phrases. It sends him into a kind of hoop slang spiral, in which it turns out, the lingo can only be explained by more lingo.
最棒的控球，最疯狂的控球。羞辱对手，摧毁对手。像任何专业领域一样，街头篮球也有专家使用的行话。这些术语对我来说听起来很酷，但从我嘴里说出来又显得很土，所以我让路易斯解释一下其中的一些短语。这让他进入了一种篮球俚语的旋转状态，事实证明，这些行话只能用更多的行话来解释。
There's so many terms. Having good handle or being crispy with the rock is having good basketball skills and fundamentally sound with the basketball. Everybody uses, but break an ankle is now having an opponent fall or they got the cowboy now. And when you're on the one leg, you're hitting a skip because somebody just broke you down. Broke you down means somebody just went by you real fast and shook you. And shook you means you're playing defense, you lost your footing, and it sort of looks like you're doing a dance step when you should have been playing defense. Dunk, make a deposit, x amount of sign. Money, Niagara Falls, reindeer games, those are all terms for making the basket in.
术语太多了。有好的控球或“球玩得脆”（crispy with the rock）是指有很好的篮球技巧和扎实的篮球基本功。大家都用，但“断掉脚踝”（break an ankle）是指让对手摔倒，或者现在他们叫“牛仔”（cowboy）。当你单脚站立时，你是在“跳步”（hitting a skip），因为有人刚把你彻底打垮了。“彻底打垮”（Broke you down）是指有人刚很快地从你身边绕过去把你晃倒了。而“晃倒”（shook you）意味着你在防守时失去了重心，当你本该防守时，看起来像在跳舞步。扣篮、存钱、一定量的签约。金钱、尼亚加拉大瀑布、驯鹿游戏，这些都是投篮进球的术语。
Luis never had a shot at the pros. There was no way he was going to make a living at basketball. He 5'10'', a decent but not great high school player who mostly sat on the bench. Like thousands of other guys who played ball when they were young, Luis's basketball fate seemed clear enough. He'd play the occasional pickup game, maybe join a local rec league, and years from now he'd settle into a Barcalounger and watch hoops on TV and complain about how kids these days have no respect for the game.
路易斯从没机会进入职业队。他不可能靠打篮球谋生。他身高5英尺10英寸，是一个不错但算不上顶尖的高中球员，大部分时间坐在板凳上。像成千上万年轻时打球的其他孩子一样，路易斯的篮球命运似乎很清楚。他会偶尔打打野球，也许加入当地的娱乐联盟，多年以后，他会坐进舒适的摇椅里，看着电视上的篮球赛，抱怨现在的孩子对这项运动没有尊重。
But then one night he got a call from a friend telling him about an audition for a Nike commercial the very next day over in Manhattan.
但后来有一天晚上，他接到了一个朋友的电话，告诉他第二天在曼哈顿有一个耐克广告的试镜。
There was a little gym on the third floor. And yeah, a little gym on the third floor. So we walked in. And I'm so used to my little bubble, I mean nobody around my area does the stuff that I do, I stand out. But then I enter a room where everybody's doing pretty much the same thing, guys doing this for a living-- Harlem Globetrotters and Wizards and NBA players.
三楼有个小体育馆。是的，三楼有个小体育馆。我们就走了进去。我太习惯于我的小泡泡了，在我的周围没有人做我做的事，我很显眼。但后来我走进一个房间，每个人基本上都在做同样的事情，靠这个为生的人——哈林篮球队的、巫师队的和NBA球员。
So I turned to my father and I was like, oh man. I didn't even think it was going to be like this. My eyes grew. And it was like a basketball court. Everybody was crowded around the court and I was one of the last ones. Everybody was starting to leave, the crowd was starting to go. I was actually the last one.
所以我转向我父亲，心想，天哪。我没想到会是这样。我的眼睛瞪大了。就像一个篮球场。每个人都围在球场边，我是最后几个到的。大家开始离开，人群开始散去。我其实是最后一个。
I started doing my thing, doing tricks and things that most of the other guys they had never seen somebody do. Everybody started coming back in the room and filling up again. So I'm like, I don't know if this is good news or bad news. But I was so in the zone. And from there on, after I was done, everybody came up to me and was like, where are you from? They looked at me like I had three heads and I was from Mars. They were like, I never seen you around. I never seen nobody do the stuff you do.
我开始做我的东西，做那些大多数人从没见过别人做的技巧。每个人又开始回到房间里，再次挤满了人。所以我想，我不知道这是好消息还是坏消息。但我当时太投入了。从那以后，结束后，每个人都走过来问我：你从哪来的？他们看着我，好像我有三个头，是从火星来的。他们说，我从来没见过你。我从没见过有人做你做的这些动作。
I had to call, the next day I was working part-time in a local mall at the Athlete's Foot, here in Woodbridge Mall. And I got on the phone and her name was Kim. And she saw me at the audition yesterday and she wants me to come to the studio. So I hung up on her.
第二天我得打个电话，我在当地伍德布里奇购物中心的运动鞋店做兼职。我打电话过去，接电话的人叫金。她昨天在试镜时看到了我，想让我去演播室。所以我挂了她的电话。
Wait, you hung on because you thought--
等等，你挂了，因为你觉得——
I thought it was somebody trying to clown me. One of my friends trying to pull a prank. Because if it was really her, then she would have been like, why'd you hang up the phone? So then she calls again and we got disconnected, she said. I was going, I guess it is for real.
我以为是有人想戏弄我。我的某个朋友想搞恶作剧。因为如果真的是她，她应该会问，你为什么挂电话？所以她又打了过来，她说我们通话中断了。我想，看来是真的。
So then she's telling me if I could come to the Kaufman Studios in Astoria, Queens. Tuesday. Everybody thought you were the best one and they want you for this commercial. They want you for this commercial.
于是她告诉我能不能周二去皇后区阿斯托利亚的考夫曼制片厂。每个人都认为你是最好的，他们想让你拍这个广告。他们想要你来拍这个广告。
March 20, I'll never forget. That was one of the best days of my life. Other guys came out. A Train came on. Chris Franklin, that was the one who was spinning the ball on the floor. Also PV Kirkland was there. He's a street diplomat with basketball. He started crossovers and all that. And they had Jackie, the famous Globetrotter. I'm in a room all full of celebrities and players that I grew up inspired by and want to be like and enjoy their style of basketball.
3月20日，我永远不会忘记。那是我生命中最棒的日子之一。“火车”来了。克里斯·富兰克林，就是那个在地上转球的人。还有PV·柯克兰也在那。他是街头篮球的外交官。他开始了交叉运球之类的。还有杰基，著名的哈林队员。我待在一个充满了名人和球员的房间里，我从小就受他们启发，想变得像他们一样，享受他们的篮球风格。
We had a little water break. Actually, PV Kirkland, he actually got up off his seat and shook my hand and said, I've been around a lot of basketball players and seen a lot of things, but I ain't never seen somebody do the stuff you do. That was the ultimate.
我们休息喝了点水。其实，PV·柯克兰从座位上站起来，和我握手说，我见过很多篮球运动员，见过很多事情，但我从没见过有人能做你做的这些。那是极致的赞美。
What about the pro guys, did they say anything to you?
那些专业球员呢，他们跟你说了什么吗？
Yeah, Barry Davids is real cool. He's like, Lu, you got to teach me some of this stuff. I was like, Barry Davids, I'll teach you some of this if you do me a favor and pull it off at some of the games. And he started laughing. But he got handle.
是的，巴里·戴维兹真的很酷。他说，卢，你得教我一些这些技巧。我说，巴里·戴维兹，如果你答应帮我个忙，在比赛里展示出来，我就教你。他开始笑了。但他确实有控球技术。
Paul Pierce though, that's my man. He couldn't spin the ball around his fingers if his life depended on it. It was so hard to get him to spin the ball. It was tough. He was getting it. He got a little dance going. Too much for the basketball, so he could sort of bob his head to the music.
不过保罗·皮尔斯是我的哥们。如果让他靠转球指尖过活，那可难了。让他转球太难了。很难。他正在练习。他跳了一点舞。对篮球来说太多了，所以他能随着音乐晃动头部。
Right. They just have him dancing around the ball.
对，他们只是让他围着球跳舞。
It was real fun. It was real fun.
真的很有趣。真的很有趣。
A couple of months later, Luis was out driving around when he got a call from one of the guys in the ad.
几个月后，路易斯正在开车时，接到了广告中一个家伙的电话。
He's like, Lu, called me all excited. He's like, Lu, your commercial's on right now. He's like, the commercial is so hot. And he's like, hold on. He's like bowl commercial break your commercial's going on. Your commercials going on like eight, nine times. Every time they put in a timeout, the commercial's going on. And they got one just with you.
他说，卢，非常兴奋地给我打电话。他说，卢，你的广告正在播放。他说，那个广告太火了。他说，等等。他说，每次广告间隙都在播你的广告。你的广告播了大约八九次。每次他们暂停时，广告都在播。他们甚至还有一个专门关于你的。
I said, oh yeah? Click. Yeah, right. Stop clowning me. And I didn't see it till, I believe, it was a week later. But when I seen it, I was-- I had a smile. I didn't have a smile on my face, but inside I was so lit up. I was like, man, I can't believe it. I can't believe it.
我说，哦，真的吗？挂断。是啊，没问题。别戏弄我了。我直到大约一周后才看到它。但当我看到时，我——我笑了。我的脸上虽然没笑，但内心极其激动。我想，伙计，我简直不敢相信。我简直不敢相信。
I came out to Luis's house with the tape of the commercial in my bag. I wanted to watch it with the man himself, have him describe to me in detail what went on the day they shot the ad.
我带着广告录像带去了路易斯家。我想和他本人一起看，让他详细地向我描述拍摄那天发生了什么。
Starting off the commercial. Future with his little dance. That was Dottie and that was me right there. Everybody thought that was a camera take. They couldn't believe I could really do that.
广告刚开始。那个“未来”的家伙跳着舞。那是多蒂，那是路易斯。每个人都以为那是摄像机剪辑的。他们无法相信我真的能那样做。
It's a little difficult staying calm as Luis walks me through it. I mean, I don't want to sound like a corporate flack or anything, but I think this commercial is just about the greatest thing that has ever been on television. It kicks the moon landing's ass.
当路易斯带我过一遍时，保持冷静有点难。我的意思是，我不想听起来像个企业吹鼓手什么的，但我认为这个广告简直是电视史上最伟大的东西。它比登月还要强。
I also don't want to get too enthusiastic about something that ultimately exists to sell sneakers. But there's just no denying the way the commercial captures basketball's pure improvisational beauty.
我也不想对那些最终为了卖运动鞋而存在的东西表现得太狂热。但无可否认，这个广告捕捉到了篮球纯粹的即兴美感。
There's one trick Luis does that's a little hard to explain on the radio, but it involves him capturing the ball between his elbows and lower back, in such a way that the ball seems to vanish in thin air. The first time I saw it, I thought it was done with computers.
路易斯有一个技巧在广播里很难解释，但他捕捉到了球在肘部和下背部之间的位置，球看起来似乎凭空消失了。我第一次看到时，还以为是用电脑做的。
Can I pause it for a second?
能暂停一下吗？
Yeah.
可以。
It looks like the ball is just like on a string hanging there. It's incredible.
球看起来就像挂在一根弦上。太不可思议了。
Thank you.
谢谢。
I know I'm not the only one who feels this way. This past month, Luis went to Taiwan with a few other guys from the ad to promote a street basketball event called Hip Hoop. The Nike commercial had just started running in Taiwan, and he wasn't really prepared for how he'd be greeted there.
我知道我不是唯一有这种感觉的人。过去的一个月，路易斯和广告中的其他几个家伙去了台湾，推广一个叫“街头篮球”的活动。耐克广告刚在台湾开始播放，他还没准备好在那里会受到怎样的欢迎。
In the airport outside of Taipei, Taiwanese customs officials approached him and the other guys, pointing at them and dribbling imaginary basketballs. Saying, freestyle, freestyle, over and over. And repeating the rhythm of the ad's squeaking sneakers.
在台北郊外的机场，台湾海关官员走近他和另外几个家伙，指着他们，做出拍打无形篮球的动作。一遍又一遍地说着“花式，花式”。并重复着广告中运动鞋摩擦地面的节奏。
[SAYING RHYTHM]
[节奏声]
Luis has a pile of snapshots he took on the streets of Taipei to record the hugeness of his celebrity there.
路易斯有一堆他在台北街头拍的快照，记录了他那里的巨大名气。
They had posters and billboards of me all over Taipei. I was shocked. I was taking pictures all over. Everywhere I would turn there would be another posted of me. They had, actually, basketball courts in every park of my face on it.
他们在台北到处都有我的海报和广告牌。我惊呆了。我到处都在拍照。无论我转身看哪里，都会有另一张我的海报。他们甚至在每个公园的篮球场上都有我的脸。
So here you are, it looks like it's about 50 feet high, this poster.
所以这里，这张海报看起来大约有50英尺高。
I got to ask you about once specific move. You hold the ball in your hand and you go as if you're throwing it towards the camera. And somehow, the ball rolls back on your hand.
我得问你一个具体的动作。你拿着球，做出好像要把它扔向摄像机的样子。然后不知怎么地，球滚回了你的手上。
It's like you're going to throw the ball forward. You roll the ball back, you get the spin back, and you try to stop it. But you do it with one hand, so it's like a motion--
就像你要把球向前扔。你把球往回滚动，获得旋转，然后试图停住它。但你只用一只手做，所以它就像一个动作——
Luis can explain to me all the tricks he wants. But what he can't really put into words when I ask him is what it's like to go so quickly from selling Nikes at the local mall in more of a one-on-one, is there enough room for your toes kind of way, to travelling halfway around the globe to a place where photos of him dominate entire city blocks? And what I can't explain is the effect this commercial has had on me.
路易斯可以向我解释他想做的所有技巧。但当我也问他从在当地购物中心卖耐克鞋、那种问“你的脚趾够地方吗”的推销员，到旅行半个地球去到一个照片覆盖整个街区的城市，是什么样的感觉时，他真的无法用语言表达。而我无法解释的是这个广告对我产生的影响。
I've watched it dozens, maybe even hundreds of times. I keep trying to do tricks in my house that go badly awry and leave dirty basketball imprints on the walls.
我看了几十遍，甚至上百遍。我一直在家里尝试做那些技巧，结果弄得一团糟，墙上留下了肮脏的篮球印。
We're going to go outside and teach you a guys a couple tricks so when you go home, your wife's going to be like where you've been?
我们得出去教你们几个技巧，这样当你回家时，你的妻子会问你都去哪了？
Eventually, Luis takes me in his backyard to play a little one-on-one. I have to admit, it's the moment I've been waiting for. I'm 35 years old, a husband and father and total square. And I'm about to play ball with the kid who has the maddest handle in the world. He starts showing me a couple of tricks, and then starts dribbling the ball around, good-naturedly challenging me to steal it from him.
最终，路易斯带我去他后院打了一场一对一。我不得不承认，这就是我一直在等待的时刻。我35岁了，是个丈夫、父亲，是个完全古板的人。我马上要和世界上拥有最疯狂运球技术的孩子打球了。他开始给我展示几个技巧，然后开始运球，友好地挑战我从他手中抢走它。
I take a couple of half-hearted swipes and Luis taunts me little, dribbling the ball right in front of me, less than an arm's length away. And that's when I have this weird, slightly confusing pang. I start thinking, what if I steal the ball from him? I've played a lot of basketball in my life and we're in this tiny space that's about the size of a parking spot. There's actually a chance that I'll be able to take it away from him. Or that I'll look kind of like a chump if I can't get a hand on the ball at least once.
我做了几次漫不经心的抢断，路易斯嘲弄我，在我面前运球，距离不到一个手臂。就在这时，我产生了一种奇怪的、令人困惑的刺痛感。我开始想，如果我从他手里抢到球会怎样？我这辈子打过很多篮球，而我们现在所在的这个小地方大约只有一个停车位那么大。其实我有机会把它从他手里抢过来。或者如果我一次都摸不到球，我会看起来像个傻瓜。
But then Luis begins to dribble the ball faster and faster. Sweat stains his shirt and beads on his face, and his hands move so quickly they look like wild birds. He flutters the ball along the ground in front of me, then makes it rises up one arm and roll down the other. When I swipe at it, it somehow disappears behind my head. And then, like a nickel plucked from my ear, reappears in front of my face. So close that for a nanosecond, it feels like I'm about to kiss the grainy service of the ball.
但随后路易斯开始越来越快地运球。汗水浸透了他的衬衫，在他脸上凝结成珠，他的双手移动得如此之快，看起来就像野鸟。他让球在他面前的地面上跳动，然后让它从一条手臂升起并滚下另一条手臂。当我向它拍去时，它不知怎么地消失在我头后了。然后，就像从我耳朵里掏出一枚硬币一样，又出现在我面前。如此近，以至于有一瞬间，我觉得我就要亲吻那粗糙的球表面了。
I lunge at the ball now, hoping that by sheer coincidence I might knock it away. But I know I won't. He's too good even for that, and I'm glad.
我现在向球猛扑过去，希望靠纯粹的巧合我能把它撞开。但我知道我不会。即便如此他也太强了，但我很高兴。
When Luis got to meet the stars on the set of the Nike commercial in Astoria, he was excited, sure. But he also knew that at this one thing he was their peer. What I'm feeling now is totally different. This wave of relief and giddiness comes over me. There's something reassuring in the idea that someone, through sheer determination and will, can become so impossibly blow-your-mind good. And there's something so comforting about being in the presence of such goodness, I keep on reaching out my hands and groping around like a blind man. Sometimes goofy laughing and spastic like a kid, and sometimes dead serious determined. But no matter what, my hands come back to me as empty of basketballs as the day I was born.
当路易斯在阿斯托利亚的耐克广告片场遇见明星时，他当然很兴奋。但他同时也知道，在这一件事上，他是他们的同行。我现在感觉到的完全不同。一种如释重负和晕眩感涌上心头。这种想法让人感到安慰：有人能通过纯粹的决心和意志，变得如此不可思议地令人震惊。在这种优秀者的面前，我有种非常舒适的感觉，我不断地伸出双手，像个盲人一样乱摸。有时笑得像个傻子，有时像个孩子一样痉挛，有时又是死板的认真。但无论如何，我的手中和出生那天一样，依然空空如也。
Joel Lovell in New York. If you're curious to see the Nike ad he's talking about, we have a link at our website, www.thisamericanlife.org.
乔尔·洛弗尔在纽约。如果你好奇想看他提到的那个耐克广告，我们的网站 www.thisamericanlife.org 有链接。
Coming up, I give all the good reasons for doing something very stupid. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，我将列举所有做某件极其愚蠢事情的好理由。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Meet the Pros. Stories of aspiring amateurs dropping in on the big leagues. We have arrived at act two of our program. Act two, Know When to Walk Away, Know When to Run.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目是“遇见专业人士”。讲述有抱负的业余爱好者闯入大联盟的故事。我们现在进入节目的第二部分。第二部分，“知进退，知去留”。
In May of 2001, one of the then-producers of our radio show, Starlee Kine, and I went to Las Vegas to watch the World Series of Poker with this guy named Jim McManus. McManus is this novelist who had gotten sent to the World Series of Poker to cover it by Harper's Magazine the year before. And as part of his coverage, he entered the tournament playing poker.
2001年5月，我们广播节目的时任制作人之一，斯塔莉·凯恩，和我前往拉斯维加斯，与一个叫吉姆·麦克马纳斯的人一起观看世界扑克大赛。麦克马纳斯是一位小说家，前一年被《哈珀》杂志派去报道世界扑克大赛。作为报道的一部分，他参加了扑克锦标赛。
Now usually when a reporter does a stunt like this, he's knocked out of the competition pretty fast. McManus, who had played poker all his life, but had never actually played in a tournament with professionals, came in fifth. Fifth out of over 500 entrants. He flew home with a quarter million dollars in prize money.
通常，当记者进行这样的特技表演时，他很快就会被淘汰出局。麦克马纳斯一生都在玩扑克，但从未真正在锦标赛中与专业人士交手，最终获得了第五名。在超过500名参赛者中名列第五。他带着25万美元的奖金飞回家了。
So anyway, Jim was introducing Starlee and I around to the various people who you're going to hear in this next story. People who make their livings playing poker. And some of these people, by the way, have become pretty well known in the poker explosion that's happened on TV and online and all over the country since we did this story back in 2001.
总之，吉姆把斯塔莉和我都介绍给了你在接下来的故事里会听到的各种人。那些靠打扑克谋生的人。顺便说一句，这些人中有些人在我们2001年做这个故事后的电视、网络和全国范围内的扑克热潮中变得相当出名。
So I'm talking to these poker pros and during one of the interviews I was asking somebody a question about, how much money they make? Or how many days a week do they work? And Jim, who's been listening to all these interviews, interrupts to tell the person who we're talking to, you have to understand, Ira is secretly considering leaving his job to play poker for a living.
我当时正在和这些职业牌手交谈，在其中一次采访中，我问某人一个关于他们赚多少钱，或者一周工作几天的问题。一直在听所有采访的吉姆打断了我，告诉我们正在谈话的人，你必须明白，艾拉正在秘密考虑辞职去打职业扑克。
And up until the moment he said that, that thought had not fully formed in my head. And as soon as he said it, I realized he was completely right. There was a part of me that was working on this question, should I leave my job to go play poker for a living? Even though I'd only played poker like a half dozen times in my life.
在他那么说之前，那个想法还没在我脑子里完全形成。而当他说出来的时候，我意识到他是完全对的。我内心深处确实在考虑这个问题：我应该辞掉工作去打职业扑克吗？尽管我这辈子只玩过大约六次扑克。
Watching these people play cards all day for their jobs, it just seemed so much better than any job I had ever seen or imagined. And the tricky thing is, it doesn't look that hard. It's not like pro basketball. It's not like hitting a fast ball like Alex Rodriguez. You know you can't do that. But poker, it's just cards. You know, it's only cards. How hard could that be?
看着这些人整天靠打牌为生，这看起来比我见过或想象过的任何工作都要好得多。麻烦的是，它看起来并不难。它不像职业篮球。不像像亚历克斯·罗德里格斯那样打出快球。你知道你做不到。但扑克，那只是纸牌。你知道，那只是纸牌。能有多难？
And so I spent a lot of time talking to people who had mastered the game-- my future colleagues-- trying to figure out if, in fact, it seemed attainable. They seem just like you and me when you meet them. But somehow they had figured out not only how to beat other people, but how to beat luck itself. You know, to what degree are they just regular people and to what degree do they have a kind of superpower? Like this woman.
所以我花了很多时间与那些掌握了游戏的人——我未来的同事们——交谈，试图弄清楚它是否真的可以实现。当你见到他们时，他们看起来和你我一样。但不知怎么的，他们不仅弄清楚了如何击败别人，还弄清楚了如何击败运气本身。你知道，他们到底在多大程度上是普通人，在多大程度上拥有某种超能力？比如这个女人。
My mother started teaching me how to play cards when I was five. And then I have a really big family and a really close family and we used to always when I was 8, 9, 10 years old, just play poker for pennies.
我母亲从我五岁起就开始教我玩纸牌。我们有一个非常庞大且紧密的家庭，我8、9、10岁的时候，我们总是玩几便士的扑克。
When I met her, Jen Harman had been making her living as a poker player for 13 years. Grew up in Reno. She was in her 30s, owned a bunch of dogs. Married. Do you see what I'm saying? She seems like anyone you know. Until she starts telling stories like this next one about how when she was 12, her dad would have poker games now and then. And if he started losing $300 or $400 or $500, she'd be allowed to play.
我见到她时，珍·哈曼已经做了13年的职业扑克选手。在里诺长大。她30多岁，养了一群狗。已婚。你明白我的意思吗？她看起来像你认识的任何人。直到她开始讲像下面这样关于她12岁时的故事，当时她父亲偶尔会玩扑克。如果他开始输掉300、400或500美元，她就会被允许上场。
He would put me in the game for him to get his money back. And I remember sitting with these guys who seemed like ancient because I was only 12 or 13 and thinking, wow, these guys have no idea what they're doing. And I'd take their money.
他会让我代替他上场，帮他赢回钱。我记得和这些家伙坐在一起，他们看起来很老，因为我只有12或13岁，心想，哇，这些家伙根本不知道自己在做什么。我会赢走他们的钱。
Just I'd watch people's movements and I'd watch them how they bet their hands. And just the whole psychological thing about it. They'd bet and I'd be saying in my mind, he doesn't have anything. Just all that kind of stuff.
我就是观察人们的动作，观察他们如何下注。还有关于它的整个心理过程。他们下注，我在心里说，他什么都没有。就是那种东西。
I think I always got my dad even. I don't remember a time that I didn't get him even. Like winning $500 back's a lot of money and you're like getting an allowance.
我想我总是能赢回我父亲输的钱。我不记得有哪次没帮他回本。赢回500美元是一笔不小的钱，就像拿零花钱一样。
At 16, Jen started playing in casinos. After college, after studying to go to medical school, she started playing full-time. If poker's your job, you set your own hours, choose what days to play. Jen says it will be the perfect job when she has kids. Right now her daily routine goes like this.
16岁时，珍开始在赌场玩牌。大学毕业后，在准备医学院考试后，她开始全职打牌。如果扑克是你的工作，你可以自己安排时间，选择打牌的日子。珍说当她有孩子时，这将是一份完美的工作。现在她的日常作息是这样的。
Wake at noon or 1:00 or 2:00. Hang out in the afternoon. Play with the dogs, run errands. Study Italian. Jen's new husband is Italian. Sometime between 7:00 and 9:00 at night, a few nights a week, she drops into the casino to see if there's a game or to start a game.
中午或1点或2点醒来。下午闲逛。和狗玩，跑腿。学习意大利语。珍的新丈夫是意大利人。晚上7点到9点之间的某个时间，每周几个晚上，她会去赌场看看有没有游戏，或者开启一场游戏。
Jen plays in what are probably the most expensive card games in the world in the poker room at the Bellagio Casino in Las Vegas. She shows up on a Tuesday night.
珍在拉斯维加斯百乐宫赌场扑克室玩，那可能是世界上最昂贵的扑克游戏。她周二晚上出现。
OK, I'm going to go to the box and get money.
好吧，我要去柜台取钱。
The Casino gives hard core players like Jen safe deposit boxes in a room next door to the poker room.
赌场会给像珍这样的核心玩家提供储物箱，就在扑克室隔壁的房间里。
Can I get black?
能给我黑色筹码吗？
She gets $40,000 in chips. She only needs $15,000 for this game, but she's hoping that a bigger game starts up.
她取了4万美元的筹码。这场游戏她只需要1.5万美元，但她希望开始一场更大的游戏。
Let's start something, Freddie. Let's start something.
我们开启点什么吧，弗雷迪。开启点什么吧。
You broke me, Freddie tells her.
你让我破产了，弗雷迪告诉她。
Huh? I surely didn't break you.
哈？我肯定没让你破产。
Here's something I never would have guessed. The people Jen plays with are mostly other professionals. The same people, over and over, night after night.
这里有一件事我永远猜不到。和珍一起玩的人大多是其他职业选手。同样的人，一遍又一遍，每晚如此。
And then we go out afterwards and have a drink or we go bowling or we go to dinner.
然后我们事后会出去喝一杯，或者去保龄球，或者去吃晚饭。
So you guys are all pros and basically you're just taking each other's money?
所以你们都是专业选手，基本上只是在互相赢对方的钱？
Yes. Well, there's usually like one or two people that aren't experienced and are from out of town, or are businesspeople that aren't as experienced. And they actually supply the game for everybody to make a good living.
是的。嗯，通常有一两个人经验不足，是从外地来的，或者是生意人，经验没那么丰富。他们实际上为每个人能过上好日子提供了游戏资金。
Supply the game. A delicate way to say, they lose. It turns out there are a lot of very rich guys who want the thrill of playing against the best in the world. Some nights the game has a minimum bet of $1,000. Other nights, it's $1,500 for one bet. It's not unusual for Jen to lose $100,000 in a single night.
“提供游戏资金”。这是一个委婉的说法，意思是他们输了。事实证明，有很多非常有钱的人想要体验与世界上最顶尖高手对决的快感。有些晚上的最低赌注是1000美元。其他晚上，一注是1500美元。珍在一晚输掉10万美元并不稀奇。
It's like normal, so you don't even think about it. But you know, it's hard getting to this frame of mind. Trust me. Because the first time I lost $3,000, I went home and cried like a baby. And I said, oh my gosh, that's the biggest loss I've ever taken in my life.
这很正常，所以你甚至不会去想它。但是，你知道，进入这种心态很难。相信我。因为我第一次输掉3000美元时，我回家像个婴儿一样哭了。我说，天哪，这是我一生中经历的最大损失。
When I lost $10,000, the same thing.
当我输掉1万美元时，也是一样。
When I lost $30,000, I couldn't sleep for four days.
当我输掉3万美元时，我四天没睡着觉。
When I lost $100,000 the first time in my life, I couldn't sleep for a week. But then, the next time I lost $100,000 and the next time I lost $100,000, it's like your pain threshold just goes up.
当我人生第一次输掉10万美元时，我一个星期没睡着觉。但后来，下一次我输掉10万美元，再下一次输掉10万美元，你的痛苦阈值就会提高。
Jen has made enough playing poker that she bought a new house, a huge house, with no mortgage. She just wrote a check. Play at her level, she says, she's not comfortable without $2 million as her bankroll.
珍靠打扑克赚的钱足以让她买了一栋新房子，一栋巨大的、没有抵押贷款的房子。她直接写了一张支票。她说，在她的级别玩牌，没有200万美元的资金池她会感到不舒服。
Most poker professionals, needless to say, play for lower stakes and make less money. A lot less money. I asked many different players what they made at the very beginning of their careers and the answer was usually about $150 a night. Coincidentally, about the same as casino dealers make.
不用说，大多数职业扑克选手玩的赌注较低，赚的钱也较少。少得多。我问过许多不同的选手他们职业生涯刚开始时赚多少钱，答案通常是每晚大约150美元。巧合的是，和赌场发牌员赚的差不多。
As you'd expect, poker is the kind of job where health insurance is sort of a problem. Even Jen, with all her money, is still on a family policy through her parents.
正如你所料，扑克是一种健康保险有点麻烦的工作。即使是珍，拥有这么多钱，依然依靠父母的家庭保险。
And how much skill does a person need? How much is luck a factor in all this? Consider this story.
那么一个人需要多少技巧？运气在这一切中占多大因素？考虑这个故事。
At one point during the World Series of Poker, a pro named Linda Johnson and I are standing just a few feet away from one of the tables. The cards are dealt. The World Series, they play a kind of poker called Texas Holdem where each player just gets two cards, face down, and then five cards come face up in the middle of the table for everybody to share.
世界扑克大赛期间，一位叫琳达·约翰逊的职业选手和我站在离桌子几英尺远的地方。牌发了下来。世界扑克大赛中，他们玩一种叫德州扑克的扑克，每个选手只发两张底牌，然后中间发五张公共牌，供所有人共享。
Anyway, the cards go around and a guy in his 20s named Paul Phillips, makes the first bet on the hand, $7,000. A guy in a bush hat and sunglasses calls the bet. Puts in $7,000 of his own. The dealer then lays out the first three face up cards, what they call the flop, in the middle of the table. And Linda leans into my microphone.
总之，牌发了一圈，一个叫保罗·菲利普斯的20多岁的家伙下了第一个注，7000美元。一个戴着丛林帽和墨镜的家伙跟注。放入了他自己的7000美元。发牌员随后在桌子中间发出了前三张公共牌，也就是他们所说的“翻牌”。琳达凑向我的麦克风。
The flop comes queen, nine, three. Paul bet all in. Paul at least has a pair, I believe. I would think he has a queen.
翻牌是皇后、九、三。保罗全押了。保罗至少有一对，我相信。我想他有一张皇后。
More betting happens. They flip over their cards. Paul actually has a pair of aces. The other guy has a pair of nines. Which, combined with the nine that's sitting on the table face up, gives him a set of three nines. Three of a kind beats a pair in poker, so Paul loses the hand.
随后进行了更多的下注。他们翻开了牌。保罗实际上有一对A。另一个人有一对九。这与桌上正面朝上的那张九结合，给了他三条九。在扑克中，三条大于一对，所以保罗输了那手牌。
I can't believe it.
我简直不敢相信。
Paul's feeling a little sick about this one. You're not supposed to lose with aces.
保罗对这次结果感觉有点糟。你不应该用A输掉。
Paul loses $20,000. The very next hand, each player gets his two cards face down. There's a flurry of calls and raises.
保罗输了2万美元。紧接着的下一手牌，每个选手都得到两张底牌。一阵跟注和加注。
Raphael brought it in. We've got some action here. It was brought in for $7,000. Daniel called $7,000. Tony D re-raised. He made it almost $80,000. Paul just moved all in. Now, remember, Paul got two aces beat last hand.
拉斐尔开始的。我们这里有点动静。他下了7000美元。丹尼尔跟注7000美元。托尼·D加注了。他加到了近8万美元。保罗直接全押了。现在，记住，保罗上一手牌刚刚用两张A输掉。
A bunch of other people drop out, leaving just two people in the hand, Paul and the guy named Tony D. Each of them has $72,000 in the pot, which is every last chip for Tony D. Because Tony D couldn't bet any more-- even if he wanted to-- they each flip over their two face down cards. Tony D has two jacks. Paul has two aces. Again.
其他人纷纷弃牌，只剩下两个人，保罗和一个叫托尼·D的家伙。每人在底池里投入了7.2万美元，这是托尼·D的最后一枚筹码。因为托尼·D不能再下注了——即使他想——他们每个人都翻开了他们的两张底牌。托尼·D有两张J。保罗又有一对A。又是这样。
Then the flop comes and another card. And then, the last card.
然后是翻牌和另一张牌。然后是最后一张牌。
Aces. Oh my God.
A。天哪。
Jack on a river.
河牌是一张J。
It's a jack.
这是一张J。
You've been flopping aces back to back.
你居然连续两次翻牌中了A。
Painful. Back to back he had aces. Once against nines, once against jack. And both times they hit their miracle. Make three nines and three jacks. So he loses two pots in a row for a lot of money. That's a brutal beat. Oh my God. Oh, Paul. Oh my God.
太痛苦了。他连续两手牌都有A。一次对抗九，一次对抗J。两次都撞上了他们的“奇迹”。凑成了三条九和三条J。所以他连续输了两个底池，损失惨重。那是极其残酷的失败。天哪。噢，保罗。天哪。
Paul's got to feel sick about this. Paul's standing up now. He's in pain. It's probably hard for him to breathe right now. Anyone who says there's no luck in this just doesn't understand.
保罗一定感觉糟透了。保罗现在站起来了。他在痛苦。他现在可能呼吸困难。谁要是说这里面没有运气，那他就是不懂。
A few hands later, Paul's lost the rest of his chips. Then his friend Melissa Hayden, a fellow pro, takes us to meet him in the casino bar.
几手牌之后，保罗输光了剩下的筹码。然后他的朋友梅丽莎·海登，一位同行，带我们去赌场酒吧见他。
What can you do? That's part of the game. It's just part of the game. It's hard to describe. When I saw that jack hit the table, I couldn't even see. I went blind for a minute. It was like it couldn't actually be a jack. It's as if you saw just something materialize out of thin air and said, that violates the laws of physics. That couldn't have just happened. This ball bearing just appeared in front of my face. That's how that jack felt. Like it just simply couldn't have happened.
你能怎么办？那是游戏的一部分。只是游戏的一部分。很难描述。当我看到那张J落在桌子上时，我甚至看不清东西。我那一刻失明了。感觉那不可能是张J。就像你看到某种东西凭空显现出来说，那违反了物理定律。那不可能就这么发生了。这个轴承球就出现在我面前。那张J就是这种感觉。就像它根本不该发生一样。
And then, standing in the bar, without notes, or pad, or paper, or anything, Paul calculates the odds that a person could get a pair of aces in two consecutive hands, and then lose both times.
然后，站在酒吧里，没有笔记、垫子或纸什么的，保罗计算了一个人连续两手牌拿到一对A，然后两次都输掉的概率。
All right, well, the odds of getting a pair of aces. You look at your first card. It's 4 out of 52, which is 1 in 13. And then the next card, 1 out of 17 because there's 3 left. 3 out of 51. 13 out of 17 is 220:1. So it's 220:1 against getting aces. Then it's 220:1 against getting them the next hand too. So we're looking at over 40,000 here because 200 squared would be 40,000.
好吧，拿到一对A的概率。你看你的第一张牌。52张牌里有4张，是1/13。然后下一张，1/17，因为只剩3张了。51张里有3张。13/17是220:1。所以拿到A的赔率是220:1。然后再拿到一对A的赔率又是220:1。所以我们这里看到的数字超过4万，因为200的平方是4万。
So then we've got the odds of me having aces cracked back to back are 4 and 1/2 squared, which is about 18. Then we got 18 times 45,000. Brings us to right around a million. And it's definitely in the milliony ballpark. What happened to me we call a 1 in a million beat.
所以我们要算的概率是我连续两手牌拿到A被反杀，是4.5的平方，大约是18。然后我们拿18乘以4.5万。把我们带到了100万左右。这绝对是在百万级的范围内。发生在我身上的事情我们称之为百万分之一的失败。
This is the sort of moment that makes the aspiring amateur player feel suddenly awestruck and frightened at all the things that the professionals have running through their heads. And this is just the odds of the game.
正是这种时刻让有抱负的业余玩家突然感到敬畏和恐惧，想到职业选手脑子里运行的所有东西。而这仅仅是游戏的概率。
At the Bellagio, Jen is having a good night, catching good cards. And the most noticeable thing about watching her play is that, like a great ballplayer, she does not seem like she's trying very hard. All at the same time, she is watching the other players, figuring out what they have, calculating the odds in her bets, ordering hot tea, conducting an interview, chatting about her upcoming trip to Italy, making her own bets.
在百乐宫，珍的运气不错，抓到了好牌。看她打牌最引人注目的地方在于，像一位伟大的球手一样，她看起来并不费力。她同时在观察其他玩家，弄清楚他们有什么，计算下注的赔率，点热茶，进行采访，闲聊她即将到来的意大利之旅，同时进行自己的下注。
You raise?
你加注？
Yep. You raise?
是的。你加注？
Yep.
是的。
Jen says that the main difference between low stakes games and the higher stakes games that she plays at, is that the better players at the higher money levels, play a way more psychological game. Here's the kind of thing that she's talking about. She knows that one of the guys in this game doesn't think much of women players.
珍说低赌注游戏和她玩的高赌注游戏之间的主要区别在于，高额游戏中的更好玩家玩的是心理战。这就是她所谈论的那种情况。她知道这场游戏中的一个家伙不太看得起女选手。
He thinks I'm the worst player in the world. That I don't play well. I get the cards and I win with them and I'm just lucky. I mean, he just hates losing to a girl. It just drives him crazy. He can't see clearly when he plays me. And it's been like that for years.
他认为我是世界上最差劲的选手。我不擅长打牌。我拿到牌赢了，那只是我运气好。我的意思是，他就是讨厌输给一个女孩。这让他疯狂。他跟我玩的时候看不清局面。多年来一直如此。
And so, in one hand, she has terrible cards. And though this guy raises the bet over and over, she bets him back. And she only wins in the end with a lucky last card.
所以，在其中一手牌中，她的牌很烂。尽管这个家伙反复加注，她依然跟注。最终她只是靠最后一张幸运牌赢了。
Oh my gosh.
天哪。
She collects the chips that she's won. One of the guys at the table points at my microphone and asks her, would you have played that hand if the guy had a video camera with him?
她收回了赢得的筹码。桌上的一个家伙指着我的麦克风问她，如果那个家伙身边带着摄像机，你还会玩那手牌吗？
It wasn't a very good hand, let's put it that way.
那不是一手好牌，这么说吧。
I was just wondering. Why would she play a hand like that?
我只是好奇。为什么她会玩那样的一手牌？
Well, the reason why she would play a hand like that has to do with that guy who doesn't think that women play good poker. She wants him to keep thinking she doesn't know what she's doing. That makes them make the wrong decisions, stay in hands that he should never stay in.
嗯，她会玩那样一手牌的原因和那个认为女人不会打好扑克的家伙有关。她想让他继续认为她不知道自己在做什么。那会让他做出错误的决定，留在本不该留下的手牌中。
I wasn't supposed to win that hand. He had buried aces. I had a dead three. And he was so much more of a favorite than I was. But I also knew that I'd make more money in the future from him if I play that hand. So if I lost the pot, I took a small loss for how much I'm going to make in the future because he thinks that I play those kind of hands against him all the time. So it's like putting myself in a negative equity situation to make more money in the future.
我本不应该赢那手牌。他有暗三条A。我只有一张死三。他比我更有优势。但我也知道，如果我玩那手牌，我将来能从他身上赚更多的钱。所以如果我输了底池，我只是为我将来要赚的钱做了一笔小额损失，因为他认为我一直那样跟他玩。所以这就像把自己置于一种负期望值的情况下，以便在未来赚更多的钱。
Many poker pros we met have no interest in other kinds of gambling. They don't exactly look at poker as gambling. Others gamble compulsively on all sorts of stuff.
我们遇到很多职业扑克选手对其他赌博根本没兴趣。他们并不完全把扑克看作赌博。其他人则在各种各样的事情上强迫性地赌博。
One of the best poker players on the circuit is known to take his winnings and blow them at the craps table. During the World Series of Poker, at one of the breaks, producer Starlee Kine and I noticed Phil Gordon. For Phil, betting is just part of life. He bets on gin rummy. He bets on cribbage. He bets on golf. He bets on backgammon.
赛场上最优秀的扑克选手之一以把赢来的钱在掷骰子桌上输光而闻名。世界扑克大赛期间，在一次休息时，制作人斯塔莉·凯恩和我注意到了菲尔·戈登。对菲尔来说，赌博只是生活的一部分。他打金拉米牌要赌。玩双陆棋要赌。打高尔夫球要赌。玩双陆棋还要赌。
I love gambling. You know, I'll gamble on anything.
我爱赌博。你知道，我什么都赌。
Really?
真的吗？
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
Like what? What's the smallest thing you've ever bet on?
比如什么？你赌过最小的事情是什么？
Well, I lost $5,000 in rock, scissors, paper last weekend.
嗯，上周末我在剪刀石头布上输了5000美元。
Wait, rock, scissors, paper. You mean the--
等等，剪刀石头布。你是说那个——
Rock, scissors, paper. The one, two, three. $5,000.
剪刀石头布。那个“一、二、三”。5000美元。
To who?
输给谁了？
To this guy.
输给这个家伙了。
This guy turns out to be his friend Rafe, who travels everywhere with him, in a free-floating, vacation slash gambling trip that never ends. Rafe, who can somehow out-think and out-strategize Phil in rock, scissors, paper.
这个家伙原来是他的朋友雷夫，和他到处旅行，在一段永无止境的假期兼赌博之旅中。雷夫竟然能在石头剪刀布上胜过菲尔并制定策略。
We've been playing rock, scissors, paper for 10 years and I've seen all the moves. You think that there's just rock, scissors, and paper. But when someone goes paper five times in a row, and you're like, OK, I know what he's doing next time, he's going paper. He's trying to sucker me into thinking he's going scissors. So you go rock and he goes paper again. It really can put you on the most serious tilt.
我们玩石头剪刀布已经10年了，所有的招数我都见过了。你认为只有石头、剪刀和布。但当有人连续五次出布时，你会想，好吧，我知道他下次要干什么，他要出布。他想诱骗我以为他要出剪刀。所以你出石头，他却又出了布。这真的能让你陷入最严重的崩盘状态。
Phil describes the strategy of rock, scissors, paper. And really, it's just like poker, he says. You only have three possible options. In one game, it's call, or raise, or fold. In the other, it's rock, or scissors, or paper. And how both are pysch out games.
菲尔描述了石头剪刀布的策略。他说，真的，这就像扑克一样。你只有三个可能的选项。在一种游戏中，是跟注、加注或弃牌。在另一种中，是石头、剪刀或布。两者都是心理博弈。
And before I know it, we're in the casino bar and Phil is rock, scissors, papering Starlee for a drink.
我还没回过神来，我们就已经在赌场酒吧里了，菲尔正在和斯塔莉玩石头剪刀布赌一杯酒。
She has just gone scissors followed by paper. Which tends to lead me to believe that she's going rock next. Just to do the full gamut of the moves. But that might be too obvious for her, so she might double reverse me.
她刚才出了剪刀，接着出了布。这让我倾向于认为她接下来会出石头。只是为了做全套动作。但那对她来说可能太明显了，所以她可能会用双重反转来对付我。
OK, I can tell her what you're going to go and I'll make it--
好吧，我能告诉她你要出什么，我能让她——
OK, I'm going to go rock.
好吧，我要出石头。
Now you better win this.
你最好赢了这场。
I'm going to go rock.
我要出石头。
I have money on you.
我把钱压在你身上了。
I'm going to go rock.
我要出石头。
People start placing side bets. Phil looks right in Starlee's eyes as he declares he's going to go rock. And this totally psyches her out.
人们开始下边注。菲尔直视斯塔莉的眼睛，宣称他要出石头。这完全让她的心理崩溃了。
I promise you.
我向你保证。
Starlee gets this look on her face that says, is he going rock? Wait, is he?
斯塔莉脸上的表情仿佛在说，他要出石头吗？等等，他要吗？
One, two, three. Oh.
一，二，三。噢。
He did.
他出了。
He goes rock. She loses.
他出了石头。她输了。
Now I'm on the juice and I want to keep doing it.
现在我上瘾了，我还想继续。
Parents, see how kids get hooked?
家长们，看到孩子们是怎么上瘾的了吗？
Phil and Rafe were in computers, their companies went public, internet boom. You know the rest of the story. Millions of dollars, no need to work. And they make a good case for why, given a choice of doing anything in the world, one might decide to play poker.
菲尔和雷夫以前做电脑生意，公司上市，互联网繁荣。你知道故事的结局。几百万美元，无需工作。他们很好地解释了为什么，如果可以选择做世界上任何事，一个人可能会决定打扑克。
It's a great life, Phil says. A constant field trip with your friends. Flying around the world, playing cards. And hearing him and Rafe describe it is really like listening to the devil telling you to quit your job, don't heed the advice of your loved ones, turn your back on everything you have ever fought for or held dear, to come and live forever on the Island of the Lost Boys.
菲尔说，这是一种伟大的生活。和朋友们不断的实地考察。环游世界，打牌。听他和雷夫描述这些，真的就像在听魔鬼告诉你辞掉工作，不要听从亲人的建议，背弃你曾经为之奋斗或珍惜的一切，来到“迷失男孩岛”永生。
Not that Phil doesn't see the downside of all this.
这并不是说菲尔看不到这一切的负面影响。
Well, I think that was probably the number one complaint of my ex-wife. I wasn't able to grow up as fast as the love of my life wanted me to. So I always want to live a life of fun and excitement and adventure. I'll do pretty much whatever it takes to make sure that continues. I mean, I have a failed marriage. I'd been married for six months. I got married October 1 and we just split up about a month ago.
嗯，我认为那可能是我的前妻提出的第一大抱怨。我没能像我一生挚爱所希望的那样快速成长。所以我总是想过一种充满乐趣、兴奋和冒险的生活。我几乎愿意付出一切来确保这种情况持续下去。我的意思是，我有一段失败的婚姻。我结婚六个月。我10月1日结婚，我们一个月前刚分手。
No, it's OK. I mean, it's very amicable. We just realized that our life goals are different.
不，没关系。我的意思是，这非常友好。我们只是意识到我们的生活目标不同。
Phil's moving to Las Vegas. Where else can you get world class entertainment seven nights a week, he asks?
菲尔要搬到拉斯维加斯。他问道，还有什么地方能让你每周七晚享受到世界级的娱乐？
It's getting late. Rafe turns to Phil before we go.
天色已晚。我们离开前，雷夫转向菲尔。
$500 this won't make the air.
500美元，这节目播不出去。
What kind of odds are you willing to give me.
你愿意给我什么样的赔率。
Even up.
平局。
I'll take 3:2.
我赌3:2。
How about you give me 3:2?
要不你给我3:2？
My $750 to your $500 that we never make the air.
我出750美元赌你500美元，我们永远不会播出。
You're on.
赌了。
Sorry, Rafe. You lose.
抱歉，雷夫。你输了。
In the months since Starlee and I went to the World Series, we've both gotten hooked on poker. She now plays in a weekly game. I've played nearly every night. Sometimes with friends, sometimes on the river boats just 25 minutes from my office at the public radio station. But most often, online for real money.
自从斯塔莉和我去世界扑克大赛后的几个月里，我们俩都迷上了扑克。她现在参加每周的游戏。我几乎每天晚上都打。有时和朋友，有时在离我公共广播电台办公室25分钟路程的内河船上。但大多数时候，是在网上玩真钱游戏。
Sometimes I'll be sitting in my office or out to dinner with friends, and I'll daydream about poker.
有时我会坐在办公室里，或者和朋友出去吃饭，就会幻想扑克。
When poker's your job, apparently, you daydream about other things that gets taken from you. While Jen and Phil and Paul all still love playing poker, there are also guys like this longtime Vegas player.
显然，当扑克是你的工作时，你对其他事情的幻想会被夺走。虽然珍、菲尔和保罗都依然热爱打扑克，但也有像这位在维加斯打牌已久的选手。
My name is Mike Laing. L-A-I-N-G. My dad always told me the I is for intelligence.
我叫迈克·莱恩。L-A-I-N-G。我爸爸总是告诉我，那个I代表智慧。
For you, after playing for so long, how often is it just like a job?
对你来说，打了这么久之后，它多久才像一份工作？
Every minute of it is a job. From the time I get up off my couch to where I have to go take a shower is a job.
每一分钟都是工作。从我从沙发上起来到不得不去洗澡，这都是工作。
I don't feel like getting in the water, washing my hair, and taking a shower and getting dressed up and this and that and going out. That's when the work begins.
我不想去洗澡、洗头、穿好衣服、做这个那个然后出门。那就是工作开始的时候。
Mike says that when he's playing poker, it is literally boring for him. In contrast to all these 20-something poker pros who are smart about their money and managing risk, Mike is old school. He never read a book about poker. Why read them when he plays against the guys who wrote the books? He's the kind of gambler who recently bet $24,000 on whether a coin flipped in the air would come up heads or tails. He won.
迈克说，当他打扑克时，对他来说这简直是无聊。与所有这些精明管理资金和风险的20多岁职业牌手相比，迈克是老派的。他从来没读过扑克书。当他与那些写书的人比赛时，为什么要读它们？他就是那种最近下注2.4万美元赌抛硬币是正面还是反面的赌徒。他赢了。
That's part of a gambler. Then the next month you're broke. And that's the way it goes. It goes up and it goes down.
这就是赌徒的一部分。然后下个月你就破产了。这就是它的运作方式。它有涨有跌。
Do you have a bankroll that you keep to protect you for a month, two months?
你有没有为了保护自己而留出的资金池，维持一个月、两个月？
Well, see a lot of guys keep their bankroll, their gambling bankroll and their spending bankroll. Me, it's like my bankroll is whatever I have. It's always up for grabs.
嗯，看，很多人保留他们的资金池，他们的赌博资金池和日常开销资金池。对我来说，我的资金池就是我拥有的任何东西。它总是处于被掠夺的边缘。
Wow.
哇。
I'll flip a coin for it or whatever.
我可以为它抛硬币，随便什么。
So you'll let yourself go broke?
所以你会让自己破产？
Well, yes. I have the heart to risk everything. If I think he's bluffing, I'll just move in on him. I'll just risk everything. It doesn't matter. If you get broke, you get broke. You just go on the next day, that's all.
嗯，是的。我有冒险一切的勇气。如果我认为他在虚张声势，我就会对他全押。我就是会冒险一切。没关系。如果破产了，就破产了。第二天继续就行，就是这样。
One day Mike was walking by his 11-year-old son at home who was playing poker online. Mike noticed his son had a killer hand, the best possible cards of anybody in that hand. Bets were happening. Mike suggested that his son raise. The son said, nah. I don't want to lose the guy, dad. Meaning he didn't want the guy to fold. He wanted to string him along, get more of his money.
有一天，迈克走过他正在网上玩扑克的11岁儿子身边。迈克注意到他儿子有一手必杀的牌，是那手牌中最好的牌。当时正在下注。迈克建议他儿子加注。儿子说，不。爸爸，我不想吓走那个家伙。意思是说他不想让对方弃牌。他想把他套住，赢他更多的钱。
I'm thinking at 11 years old, to pick up this lingo and to realize this, I mean, he could have potential to be a great poker player. But I mean, it'd be nice for him to have that as a hobby, like a secondary thing. I'd like to have him go onto college and be a doctor or a lawyer or something.
我想，在11岁时能学会这种行话并意识到这一点，我的意思是，他有潜力成为一名伟大的扑克选手。但我的意思是，如果他把这作为一种爱好，作为第二职业会很好。我希望他能上大学，成为一名医生或律师什么的。
And would you be sad if he became a professional poker player?
如果他成为一名职业扑克选手，你会难过吗？
I don't want him in it. I don't want him in it. I mean, I got a lot of friends all over the world and I got a lot of respect from friends all over the world. And he'd have a lot of friends. And he'd hear stories of his dad all the world, and I'm sure of that. Because I mean, I put some stories out there. Not meaning to, but I've put out a lot of stories that people will be talking about for years after I'm gone. But I want him to have something else to fall back on that he knows is going to be there.
我不希望他进入这个行当。我不希望他进入。我的意思是，我在世界各地有很多朋友，我在世界各地得到了很多尊重。他也会有很多朋友。他会听到全世界关于他父亲的故事，我确信这一点。因为我的意思是，我讲了一些故事。不是故意的，但我讲了许多故事，即使我不在了，人们也会谈论好几年。但我希望他有别的东西作为后盾，他知道那是会一直存在的。
Poker will bus you. It's built into the job that experienced players go on losing streak that last months. No player can avoid it. Think about what that does to you.
扑克会毁了你。资深玩家经历长达数月的连败是工作的一部分。没有玩家能避免。想想这对你意味着什么。
It makes you mean with your kids, your wife, or whoever you're with and you're irritable. People come up to talk to you, you don't want to talk to them. You kind of like fly of the hand and say I'm sorry. I had a bad day.
这会让你对你的孩子、妻子或无论和谁在一起时变得刻薄，你会变得急躁。人们过来和你说话，你不想理他们。你可能会突然失去控制，然后说对不起。我今天心情不好。
You know it's supposed to all balance out, but it's like you think, God, why? Why has it got to balance out now? Why can't it balance out a little bit later or not so strong?
你知道它本来应该平衡的，但你心想，天哪，为什么？为什么非要现在平衡？为什么不能晚点平衡或者不要那么强烈？
The night we went with Jen Harman to the casino she won $16,000 in two hours. But she spent most of the last three months on a huge losing streak. She says it doesn't worry her. She knows it will change. When she first started playing poker, it was different.
我们和珍·哈曼去赌场的那个晚上，她在两个小时内赢了1.6万美元。但过去三个月她大部分时间都处于巨大的连败中。她说这并不让她担心。她知道情况会改变。她刚开始玩扑克时，情况不同。
She'd only been playing seriously for a year and a half when she went on a seven-month losing streak.
她在连败七个月的时候，才认真玩扑克一年半。
You doubt yourself. I tried not to change my game for the worst. And a lot of poker players, that's why poker's so difficult, and so many people can't be successful, is because they go through these losing streaks and they start to play really bad. They really change their game for the worst. I mean, you have to be robotic. And that's very difficult to do. I don't know how many times I've said, man, I wish I was a robot. Why can't I be a robot? No emotion at all.
你会怀疑自己。我努力不让自己的状态变差。许多扑克选手——这就是为什么扑克如此困难，为什么那么多人无法成功的原因——是因为他们经历了这些连败，他们开始打得很烂。他们真的让自己的状态变得更糟。我的意思是，你必须像机器人一样。这非常难做到。我不知道我说了多少次，天哪，我希望我是个机器人。为什么我就不能是个机器人？完全没有情感。
She keeps track of her wins and losses. And in 3 of the 13 years that she's been playing, she took a loss. She's gone broke once. Nearly gone broke a second time. This is all very sobering news for the aspiring professional.
她记录她的输赢。在她玩扑克的13年里，有3年她是亏损的。她破产过一次。第二次差点破产。这对有抱负的专业选手来说都是非常清醒的消息。
I find it's hard to quit poker, though. Even though playing just these last few months, it's clear that I don't have a special gift for the game. I don't have the patience. I get bored waiting for a good hand, and then play all kinds of cards I really should be folding. This has cost me frankly, a bit of money.
我发现很难戒掉扑克。尽管在这最后几个月里玩牌，显然我并没有玩扑克的天赋。我没有耐心。我厌倦了等待好牌，然后打出各种我本该弃掉的牌。老实说，这让我花了一些钱。
Another weakness of mine, I find I'm often more interested in knowing whether people are lying than I am in winning money. So if I have a pair of aces and then somebody keeps raising the bets as though they have a straight, or trips, or something that would beat my aces, the right thing to do would be to fold. I like to flatter myself to think it's a reporterly instinct kicks in. And then I simply want to know if they're bluffing. And so I stay in.
我的另一个弱点是，我发现我对知道别人是否在撒谎比赢得金钱更感兴趣。所以，如果我有一对A，然后有人不断加注，好像他们有顺子、三条，或者什么能击败我A的东西，正确的做法应该是弃牌。我喜欢自我陶醉，认为这是记者直觉在起作用。我只是想知道他们是否在虚张声势。所以我跟注了。
If they're bluffing, it's so interesting. It's so interesting how people act in different situations. That is more interesting to me than winning the money. Starlee says that when I say in like this, I'm basically a girl. You know, watching sports for the personalities rather than caring about who is going to win. So I stay in. They are almost never bluffing.
如果他们在虚张声势，那太有趣了。人们在不同情况下的表现非常有趣。这比赢得钱对我来说更有趣。斯塔莉说，当我这样跟注时，我基本上就是个女孩。你知道，看体育节目是为了看球员性格，而不是关心谁会赢。所以我跟注了。他们几乎从不虚张声势。
Just about two weeks ago, I started lying about money. I've been telling people that I'm down about $150 total for all this poker. But really, it's more like $300. OK, it's $350. That's bad, right? The lying.
就在两周前，我开始在钱的事情上撒谎。我一直告诉人们，我玩扑克总共亏损了大约150美元。但实际上，更像是300美元。好吧，是350美元。那是很糟糕的，对吧？撒谎这件事。
I asked Jen Harman how many hours an amateur like me would take to get competent at poker. And she thinks for a moment and then says, 2,000. 2,000 hours. Think of that. That's like a 40-hour-a-week job for a year. I only have 1,930 hours to go.
我问珍·哈曼像我这样的业余爱好者需要多少小时才能达到扑克胜任水平。她想了一会儿，然后说，2000。2000小时。想想看。那就像是一年40小时一周的工作。我还有1930小时要走。
Act three, Martha, My Dear.
第三部分，“亲爱的玛莎”。
Well, David Rakoff is our third amateur today. An amateur who set out on the quest to meet the pros, to get a question answered.
好了，大卫·拉科夫是我们今天的第三位业余选手。一位出发去寻找专业人士、寻求答案的业余选手。
I have a cupboard in my living room, a freestanding armoire that holds, among a ton of other stuff, the following supplies. Six stamp pads, rubber linoleum printing blocks, seven boxes of Chinese flash cards, bindery fabric sample books from the garbage of the carpet and tile store on 20th, acrylic paints-- approximately 40 tubes-- rhinestones, pearl buttons, architectural balsa wood, pipe cleaners, and a tin cracker box of golf tees. Quantity, approximately 1,000 assorted colors.
我在客厅里有个柜子，一个独立的衣柜，里面装满了各种东西，包括以下用品。六个印台、橡胶油毡印刷块、七盒中国闪卡、从第20街地毯和瓷砖店垃圾里捡来的装订织物样本册、丙烯颜料——大约40管——水钻、珍珠纽扣、建筑用轻木、管道清洁剂，还有一个饼干盒，里面装满了高尔夫球钉。数量大约1000个，颜色各异。
I make stuff. Boxes, lamps, mirrors, small folding screens, painted jackets for kids, that kind of thing. It's what I do in my spare time. Some people need to exercise every day, my salvation lies in time spent alone with an X-acto knife and commercial-grade adhesive.
我制作东西。盒子、灯、镜子、小型折叠屏风、为孩子们画的夹克，这类东西。这是我闲暇时做的事。有些人每天都需要锻炼，而我的救赎在于独自与美工刀和商业级粘合剂相处的时光。
During the act of making something, I experience a kind of blissful absence of the self and a loss of time. I almost cannot get this feeling any other way. Certainly, it never happens in my job in writing.
在制作某物的过程中，我体验到一种幸福的自我消失和时间的丧失。我几乎无法以任何其他方式获得这种感觉。当然，这从来没在我的写作工作中发生过。
When seated at the computer, I have to either check my watch, eat something, call a friend, or abuse myself every 10 minutes. By contrast, I once spent 16 hours making 150 wedding invitations by hand and was not for one instant of that day tempted to check the time.
坐在电脑前，我每10分钟就得看表、吃点东西、打个电话或虐待自己。相比之下，我曾花16小时手工制作了150份婚礼请柬，那一整天里我没有一刻想看时间。
Is it possible for one's job to be an exercise in having that feeling? Or does the act of doing something for money automatically rob you of that feeling? For me, there was only one place where I could find the answer-- the crafts department of Martha Stewart Living magazine.
一个人有可能将工作变成一种拥有那种感觉的练习吗？或者说，为了钱而做某件事会自动剥夺你那种感觉吗？对我来说，只有一个地方能找到答案——《玛莎·斯图尔特生活》杂志的工艺部。
It's kind of messy.
这有点乱。
You're the luckiest person I've ever met.
你是我见过的最幸运的人。
My voice is squeaking in Hannah Milman's office. Hannah is the editor who heads up the crafts department, and her workspace has me green with envy. There is the requisite desk with telephone and computer, but beyond that it's just an embarrassment of fantastic art supplies.
我的声音在汉娜·米尔曼的办公室里尖叫。汉娜是负责工艺部的编辑，她的工作空间让我嫉妒得发绿。那里有必备的办公桌、电话和电脑，但除此之外，那里简直堆满了梦幻般的艺术用品。
Numerous apothecary jars filled with sea shells, bags upon bags of quartz, polished oyster shells, beads, vintage rhinestones, spools of ribbon, silk flowers. It is an astonishing array.
无数装满贝壳的药剂瓶、一袋袋石英、抛光的牡蛎壳、珠子、古董水钻、缎带卷、丝绸花。这真是一个惊人的阵列。
Did you blow these eggs yourself or did you get them--
你是自己把这些蛋吹干的，还是你把它——
A lot of them, yeah.
很多都是的，是的。
On one of the shelves is a series of decorated eggs that have been sawed open with the tiny bit of a dremel drill, painted, hinged, altered, and adorned in innumerable variations on opulence. Hannah explains that these were created in-house for a feature the magazine did on how to make your own Faberge eggs.
其中一个架子上有一系列装饰过的蛋，它们是用微型旋转钻头锯开的，经过涂漆、铰接、改造和装饰，呈现出无数奢华的变体。汉娜解释说，这些是为杂志制作的关于如何制作自己的法贝热彩蛋专题而在内部创作的。
When we did this costume story, one of our projects was a witch made out of plastic drawstring garbage bags, plastic drawstring garbage bags.
当我们做这个服装故事时，我们的项目之一就是用塑料拉绳垃圾袋制作的女巫，塑料拉绳垃圾袋。
The story was to do costumes out of found objects.
故事的内容是用现成的物品制作服装。
Well actually, it was no-sew costumes.
嗯，事实上，是无缝服装。
No sew costumes.
无缝服装。
The requirement is that they could not be sewn.
要求是它们不能缝制。
So you're given a problem. That's the problem. Let's do it. That's a great idea.
所以你得到了一个问题。这就是问题。让我们做吧。那是个好主意。
So I went to go look for garbage bags. And as everybody here does, you search for the perfect garbage with the right color drawstring and just the right sheen. So I was shopping and thought, there must be something else in the supermarket that would work as a costume. It wasn't really coming to me, but then there were the coffee filters. And I thought, those could be those Elizabethan cuffs around your wrist. I said, I'm going to buy these. There's something there. They remind me of the cuffs. It turned out, it was the perfect material.
所以我去寻找垃圾袋。正如这里的每个人所做的一样，你搜索带有合适拉绳颜色和恰当光泽的完美垃圾袋。所以我购物时想到，超市里一定有别的东西可以作为服装。我还没想到，但后来看到了咖啡滤纸。我想，那些可以作为你手腕周围的伊丽莎白时代的袖口。我说，我要买这些。这里面有东西。它们让我想起了袖口。事实证明，那是完美的材料。
You should have worn it for your wedding, it was so beautiful. She regrets that.
你应该在婚礼上穿它，它太美了。她后悔没这么做。
We have congregated in the main work room. The project currently underway is-- not surprisingly-- Christmas ornaments. Stalks of wheat have been soaked, folded, twisted, braided, and tied into an endless variety of shapes. Then dusted with differing shades of brilliant metallic mica powder, which requires a respirator.
我们在主工作间集合。目前正在进行的项目是——不出所料——圣诞装饰品。小麦杆被浸泡、折叠、扭曲、编织并捆绑成各种形状。然后撒上不同深浅的闪亮金属云母粉，这需要戴上呼吸器。
The women who work here-- there is one man, but curiously his name is actually Megan-- seem more like rizdy hipsters than ice cream social soccer moms. They all went to art and design school. They all seem to love their jobs. And they seemed to love them for a reason that's very familiar to me.
在这里工作的女性——有一个男人，但奇怪的是他的名字叫梅根——看起来更像是古怪的时髦青年，而不是冰淇淋社交派对的足球妈妈。她们都上过艺术设计学校。她们似乎都热爱自己的工作。而且她们热爱这些工作的原因对我来说非常熟悉。
When you're making something, do you ever achieve this state of mind where you've lost time?
当你制作某物时，你是否曾达到那种失去时间感的心理状态？
At 2 o'clock in the morning.
凌晨2点。
You get really flushed and excited.
你会感到非常脸红和兴奋。
You go into a deep level of concentration really, is what it's all about, I think. You really do. You have to be able to concentrate really deeply to the point where you don't even realize-- you're not self-conscious about what you're doing anymore. It's just flowing out of you.
我认为这就是进入一种深度的专注水平。真的。你必须能够非常深刻地集中注意力，甚至不觉得——你不再对自己在做什么感到自我意识了。它只是从你身上流淌出来。
The actual name for the state of mind that Kelly is describing is called flow, coincidentally. It's a term you may have heard of without knowing where it came from. It was coined by the psychologist Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi. For those of you not of Hungarian descent, let me say that name again. Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi.
凯利描述的这种心态的实际名称，巧合地叫做“心流”。这是一个你可能听说过但不知道它从何而来的术语。它是由心理学家米哈里·契克森米哈赖提出的。对于那些非匈牙利裔的听众，让我再说一遍那个名字。米哈里·契克森米哈赖。
Csikszentmihalyi interviewed athletes, chess players, artists, rock climbers, and found that all of them, when engaged in the act of their choosing, spoke of reaching a level of engagement that is completely unself-conscious, removes them from their everyday worries, and alters their sense of time.
契克森米哈赖采访了运动员、象棋手、艺术家、攀岩者，发现他们所有人在进行他们选择的活动时，都谈到了达到一种完全无意识的参与水平，将他们从日常烦恼中剥离出来，并改变了他们的时间感。
I think the biggest challenge for us is that you have to have like insta-flow. You have to make things. You don't have a choice. That's what you're paid for. That's what your job is.
我认为我们面临的最大挑战是，你必须拥有类似“即时心流”的东西。你必须制作东西。你没得选择。这就是你拿薪水的原因。这就是你的工作。
But has that corrupted flow in your life? When something becomes from avocation to vocation, from the thing that you love to do to the thing that you may still very well love to do, but the thing that you're paid to do, can you still create it for yourself?
但这破坏了你生命中的心流吗？当某件事从业余爱好变成职业，从你热爱做的事变成虽然可能依然很热爱但却是你被付钱做的事，你还能为自己创造它吗？
Yes you can. Yes you can. But it takes a lot of discipline. It takes a lot of discipline to keep-- you can't just sort of do it when you feel like it.
是的，你可以。是的，你可以。但这需要很大的纪律性。保持这一点需要很大的纪律性——你不能只在想做的时候才做。
Dream over. I can't work here. I just don't want to expand that kind of effort to get to a place that I can get to without any work at all. Under that kind of pressure, I'm not even sure I could get there in the first place.
梦醒了。我不能在这里工作。我只是不想投入那种努力去获得一个我不费吹灰之力就能得到的地方。在这种压力下，我甚至不确定我能不能先到达那里。
To paraphrase that famous old saying, don't flow where you pro.
用那句老话来说，不要在你专业的地方流心流。
Talking to these women, I do realize I have this in common with them. We all make stuff. We give most of it away as gifts. And for the most part, none of us seems to have a terribly clear idea of what happens to all of it after that.
和这些女性交谈，我确实意识到我和她们有共同点。我们都制作东西。我们把其中大部分当作礼物送出。而且大部分时候，我们中似乎没有谁对在那之后它们会怎么样有一个非常清楚的概念。
I have made and given away years and years worth of things, starting in earnest at least 15 years ago. Some of it to people who have moved almost that many times. Others have gotten divorced or been widowed. I've made things out of food, polyurethaned food, but food nonetheless.
我已经制作并送出了很多年的东西，至少从15年前开始认真做。其中一些送给了已经搬家很多次的人。其他人离婚或丧偶了。我曾用食物制作东西，聚氨酯食物，但不管怎样还是食物。
My hypothesis is that a lot of the things I've made spend a year on the shelf and are then consigned to the rubbish heap or the Goodwill or a box in the basement. I decided to test my theory.
我的假说是，我制作的很多东西在架子上待了一年，然后就被送进了垃圾堆、旧货店或地下室的盒子里。我决定测试我的理论。
Hello.
喂。
Deb?
黛比？
Yes.
是的。
It's David.
我是大卫。
Hey.
嘿。
Hi. I have a question for you. You're being recorded right now.
嗨。我有个问题问你。你现在正在被录音。
Oh, for crying out loud.
噢，天哪。
Do you remember that birthday-- it might have been your 30th birthday. Do you remember what I made you?
你还记得那个生日吗——可能是你30岁生日。你记得我为你做了什么吗？
Yeah, I have it right here.
记得，我就放在这儿。
You do?
你真的留着？
Yeah.
是的。
I'm surprised that Deb still has the box. Especially so close at hand.
我很惊讶黛比还留着那个盒子。尤其是随手可得的地方。
What is it?
那是什么？
It is a wooden-- is it a transformed cigar box? And it's painted in various lovely pastel shades. And then it's covered in Necco wafers. And they're topped with [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
它是一个木制的——是一个改造过的雪茄盒吗？它被涂成了各种可爱的粉彩。然后它上面覆盖着内科威化饼。上面还有 [听不清]。
It turns out that she wasn't the only one who could describe the gifts in detail. I call my friends James, Laura, and Margaret. They also kept the things I'd made for them. Not just kept them, but kept them out in their daily lives. On their bedside tables, in their hallways, on their children's backs.
事实证明，她不是唯一一个能详细描述礼品的人。我打电话给我的朋友詹姆斯、劳拉和玛格丽特。他们也都留着我为他们制作的东西。不仅是留着，而且在他们的日常生活中使用。放在床头柜上，走廊里，孩子们的背上。
In between phone calls, I postmortem with my producer Alex Blumberg. He recorded all of these calls. He wasn't surprised at all that my friends kept the stuff.
在电话之间，我和我的制作人亚历克斯·布隆伯格进行了回顾。他录下了所有这些电话。他一点也不惊讶我的朋友们留下了这些东西。
Because they love you and they're your friends and they're clearly-- you know, you're all very close. And they're going to keep everything that you give to them because they like you.
因为他们爱你，他们是你的朋友，他们显然——你知道，你们都很亲密。而且他们会留下你给他们的所有东西，因为他们喜欢你。
All right, what did you do with the little linotype that I left on your desk?
好了，你把那块我留在你桌上的小铅字放在哪了？
Fascinating.
真迷人。
What did I do with the little linotype? I totally forgot that I was a gift recipient. I got to find it now.
我把那块小铅字放哪了？我完全忘了我是礼物的接收者。我得现在找找看。
You don't have to find it now. This is the thing. You really don't have to find it now.
你不必现在就找。这就是问题所在。你真的不必现在就找。
Here's the thing. On some level, I actually don't really care what happens to the things, so long as what doesn't happen is the following, which is that 20 years hence, when these people are sitting around with their families, their new families, their children, that the sort of mythology of the object is not, oh, this was given to us by that sad, lonely loser. Do you know what I mean? Oh, he made us this thing, but he came to our wedding and got so drunk.
关键在于。在某种层面上，我其实并不真的关心这些东西会怎么样，只要不发生以下情况就行，即20年后，当这些人与家人、新家庭、孩子坐在一起时，关于这个物体的神话不是，“哦，这是那个悲伤、孤独的失败者给我们的。”你知道我的意思吗？“哦，他为我们做了这个，但他来参加我们婚礼时喝得太醉了。”
Alex really shouldn't feel bad. It's a lovely moment when I give somebody something and they're appreciative, to be sure. But in some ways, their reaction is beside the point. I'll make things anyway.
亚历克斯真的不应该感觉不好。当我给别人某种东西而他们很感激时，确实是一个可爱的时刻。但在某种程度上，他们的反应是次要的。无论如何我都会制作东西。
On some level, me giving somebody something that I've made, it's almost the equivalent of your fitness nut friend coming into your living room, dropping and giving you 25, and then shouting, Happy Birthday! Who's really gotten the gift in a transaction like that? You tell me.
在某种层面上，我给别人某种我制作的东西，几乎等同于你那个健身狂朋友走进你的客厅，让你做25个俯卧撑，然后喊道：“生日快乐！”在那样的交易中谁才是真正得到礼物的人？你告诉我。
David Rakoff is the author most recently of the book Don't Get Too Comfortable.
大卫·拉科夫是最近出版的书《别太舒服》的作者。
Original music for our poker story today by TRS 80. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
今天我们扑克故事的原创音乐由 TRS 80 提供。《美国生活》由公共广播国际分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助名单]
WBEZ management oversight for our show by Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, all he says anymore is--
WBEZ 对我们节目的管理由托里·马拉蒂亚先生监督。你知道，他只会说——
[SAYING RHYTHM]
[节奏声]
I'm Ira Glass. The I is for Ira. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。那个I代表艾拉。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。